hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play the very
organized thief now this is about as
blind as these playthroughs come because
I was literally just sold a rink
oh hell am I talking about I was
literally just sent a rink I'll link
good god what is wrong with my brain a
sent a link that said the very organized
thief and that's all I know and that's
all I'm ever gonna know okay okay
volumes up pants are off let's do this
cuz I'm not doing well apparently
alright so I'm gonna assume that I'm
going into this not very organized and
I'm gonna die
use wasa to to move hold left shift to
run by those guys and nothing else space
to interact hello
q4 checklist eat a toggle torch that's
what it's looking for q4 checklist
things to barrio radio mobile phone
statue rare wine laptop tablet jewelry
box and a gold bar okay well let's get
to it
can I turn that on I can't indeed why
would I even need it towards if I can
just turn on everything huh oh no I want
to use the e key to interact with stuff
pick up it's so physically interactable
that's so cool hot damn take mobile
phone okay that was yeah okay all right
I see what this I see what you're
driving at I see what's going on here
let me just turn on the light oh oh look
at me I'm so strong oh I'm losing it I'm
losing it oh just threw it into the
corner there ah yeah it's good I'm
organized enough oh damn oh there's a
money stacks lying around what kind of
weirdo family is
I just took us daga money all right I'm
not complaining but I'm just saying why
would this family just have stacks of
money lying around can't either radio
rare wine tablet jewelry box is this
wine is this wine there's wine down here
is that another stack of money
seriously is one of these rare how am I
supposed to know they all look the same
oh this one's the rare one okay radio
laptop tablet jewelry box gold bar
that's menacing and ominous but what
does it mean oh look another stack of
money damn they're just everywhere does
this do what does this do oh okay I
think I just set off an alarm which
would be horribly stock
I am late bone I am lay bones here's
this a lady of the house he's gonna be
mad oh don't be mad at me lady you know
it's weird it's not actually a monster
dad what are you doing I thought you
were going to pillow
she's at romping through the house what
does that mean for me
hey I escaped but I did I win win it was
hardly worth the effort I mean I sixteen
hundred dollars a lot of money but I
mean come on I didn't get anything on my
list
I got like a a tuna turnip and a spork
okay Vaz painting tablet toaster statue
computer case portrait of a lady go bar
I know what the portrait of the lady is
isn't that this right here it looks like
a portrait of a lady and this is a
statue type deal well that's easier okay
so now I need to find oh this time I
don't need the lap oh wow okay then
I'm awfully confused okay this time I
need a toaster and alrighty then I'm so
confused
I'm so confused it's awfully loud oh you
can actually see it moving oh we only
have this that's a book oh there's that
office key so I'm assuming I need to go
upstairs into an office and I guess I
need to take the stacks of money I don't
need a rare wine this time but there was
still a stack of money here whoo okay so
that's good I guess that means I need a
tablet painting or Vaz sir Oh Oh right
here okay computer case gold bar
bla bla bla bla bla bla hello-o another
stack of money seriously who are these
people that they can just leave stacks
of money lying around oh well ah crap Oh
what did I do
I did it again ah I'm so bummed I'm so
bummed the lady of the house is gonna
get me and then she's gonna nibble my
giblets one five the code was right
there I messed up oh you turkeys Bing
bong
stack money okay anyway one five four
eight four maybe I can stop it from
going
one five eight four well this doesn't
seem very worrying because nothing seems
to be happening I got a giant gold ball
why didn't they keep the rest of their
money in the safe not that it actually
made them safe
oh that lady is gonna get me she's gonna
get me oh she's gonna she's gonna give
me
I need a tablet is that oh that's a
tablet now of whose eyes oh no how am I
gonna get out I'm gonna come up the
stairs
don't see anything lady I need a Voss
I need a boy's beautiful okay I need a
vars
where the hell is a bazaar what the hell
is a vas a and I know what a Vaz a looks
like in this house you skewed the bougie
what are you doing what are what are you
doing what lady
the hell is wrong with you are you just
are you just gonna trap me here really
is really really the hell lady lady
seriously um what are you doing what are
you doing uh excuse me
I I can't I can't move you're not doing
ow ow
Oh
well there we go oh that actually scared
the crap out of you because I didn't
expect her to be there but I mean come
on what the hell happened this is kind
of fun I'm actually makes me enjoy
myself it's like a hunting thing go to
find it's like a uh thingamabob or list
a doob dabber pic tablet okay right
there office key right there don't set
off any alarms let's go through this
quickly put the TV right in my pocket
I need of Zhai and I don't know where
the oh I don't need that really money
stack stamp album where the hell is a
stamp album
where the hell is a radio and what Elsa
bazaar there is that the game console
thing no game console this is a comp
tool ah ah money stack give me I saw you
you can't hide from me and then uh you
know I guess I go upstairs in here what
if wasabi in here oh this is not going
well because I can't find anything that
I need I am so boned well let's get the
gold bar out of the safe anyway and then
hopefully we'll take it from there
8:04 for Peter case got it he's grew
money stack 8:04 for but a money stack
wouldn't a rowdy Obie buy a bed that
looks like one no what is that
Oh fine 8:04 for Bato ski oh how is that
setting off the alarm I did it right
don't do that
lose it off stop that shut up man how do
I keep setting oh there's a raw do I
need to oh there's a money stack in the
cupboard underneath the bathroom Wow
game console game console where's a game
console where the VA's ah whoa guitar no
don't need that okay
stamp album game console I don't know
where these things are okay there's the
stamp album where's the game console
[Music]
what in the hooey
there's no oh what oh I wouldn't even
have noticed that where's the visage
she's here I'm so boned I am fond I am
bond
I am bond where's the face pause oh
don't let just cop out and go out that
front door I want to get the bizarre the
hell do I get the Fasano nope nope nope
nope nope you ain't go gimme ain't gonna
get me I'm a very organized thief you
ain't gonna get me oh you want some lose
that's right get out of there
loser loser oh yeah well now oh yeah
well now what dear lady what now you
scared you're gonna call the Popo on me
didn't think so
the hell where in the hell is a
bizarre-o I don't know I don't I don't
know I don't know I can't find it you
know what can't find it there is no vase
oh hi lady are you stuck again Oh get
away from me oh you know every oh you're
disturbing yeah yeah yeah you know what
you know what you know what screw you
Oh $37,000 that's good that's good I
think I can end on that I didn't find
the vase I don't know where that was
that was actually pretty fun it was like
a little mini game not so much scary I
mean that lady was his gravy but she
startled me a few times not very scary
but not bad not bad
I didn't I didn't mind it so anyway
thank you all so much for let me just
yell that at you a little louder and as
all click the I don't know I'm having
trouble on this episode the kid say
words and talk good so I'm just gonna go
see you in later I guess
[Music]
[Applause]